Keith Kevin uh for folks who don't know
your background first of all thanks for
coming out take me right off the bat
just tell us a little bit about your
story how it came about to you guys
becoming you know YouTube phenomenons
today where everyone's wanting to learn
more about you guys well it uh it
started back in 2012. now 2010 2010.
yeah it was actually uh we just uh we
wanted to be CPA's accountants yeah but
we had this job where we was insurance
adjusters right you mean serious right
now you're joking yeah I'm serious we
work for AAA of Southern California yeah
who the hell wants to get into insurance
by the way
auto accidents and I came across YouTube
YouTube was in this infancy at the time
and I went to council with these people
on YouTube let's uh let's start doing
videos we can uh we can be comedians
literally yeah he came to my cubicle
which his cubicle was right on across
the mind he walks around and tells me I
said what are you talking about I
thought this could be a Certified Public
Accounts yeah now let me ask you while
you're doing that did you did a video
prompt you going to him or no like did
you see something and say dude we can do
better than these guys yeah I don't know
we saw a video so look at all these
views these people getting these people
are whack okay this is pride you know
yeah so uh we started doing the videos
but we're having a hard time finding the
time to do it because we had full-time
jobs at Triple A so we came up with the
great idea on our lunch break at work we
can go into the uh second floor there's
a conference room with no signage or
anything it was just the empty four it
was vacant so we would do our videos now
somehow another HR found out that we're
doing this videos in there
you forget how they found out they was
investigating this one guy right because
he was passed up for promotion so we had
did some videos with him so when he went
to his YouTube channel and he saw him
talking trash about the company right
there's me and keeping several of his
videos yeah so what happened was the HR
at the time I remember the economy it
Tanked
we was it was totally overstepped this
is 10 2010. this was yeah it was around
2011 or so yeah
so we're totally overstaffed so I
remember me and Keith was coming back
from lunch and we saw HR right I was
like whenever you see HR like oh [ __ ]
somebody's gonna get fired yeah yeah it
was this bald guy bald white guy right
because he was purely reminiscent of
what we got going on over here right
just shout out to Robert O'Rourke and he
was obviously not doesn't not that it
matters he was obviously gay he was the
gay guy we got the same situation
we're coming back from lunch and Joe's
like look hey Charles here they're gonna
find somebody and right before they
walked in the building they stopped and
looked at us
and then they walk like that's like why
the [ __ ] are they looking at us like
that
[ __ ] you not I sit down I'll clock back
in excuse me Keith um we have to see you
know in the conference room
this you're getting out of order we
[ __ ] you up so so we sit down right
I'm at my cubicle and then the uh I
remember the the managers out of office
the assistant manager comes up said Hey
Kevin um we need to talk to you for a
moment I was like oh okay I totally
forgot about it so I'm sitting down
right
and I said oh [ __ ] there's the the bald
white gay guy so we sit down he's got a
female with him and he start asking me
questions like loaded questions like
questions they already know the answer
to and I was like uh this is this about
the YouTube videos I'm doing I said yeah
I do videos but I don't say where I'm at
there's no signage nobody knows where
I'm at I don't even tell people where I
work at what's the promise of well you
use some foul language I say y'all
calling me over some foul language of a
video that nobody knows where I'm at and
it's during my lunch break while I'm off
the clock so I lost it
literally yeah because your job was so
demand you would come in in the mornings
on Monday your queue was full of uh
claims I'm on the phone all day
constantly you have no time to take a
break and I was like pissed I'm like oh
I come in here every day I bust my ass I
don't make any problems or anything and
you talk to me about some YouTube videos
some foul language that nobody heard I
mean so they was put me on a minute not
that any one of them go and take off or
not yet you guys haven't taken off yet
okay got it so it's not like one got two
million viewers and they're like hey
right everyone's calling me it was like
1500 views man it was got it yeah yeah
so uh we're getting uh like verbal
altercation they call security and all
that and they escort me out before the
escort me out I say hey he's with my
twin brother I know if you talking to me
you gotta talk to my twin brother I said
where's Keith I went to his cubicle he's
not there they already grabbed his ass
so I'm walking all over the floor Hey
where's my [ __ ] brother right so I'm
like going all the empty rooms hey hey
chief over here hey hey Larry keep going
here it did us again but I don't know
nothing so I find key piece in the
conference room sitting down with HR it
was funny when I was in that talking it
was asking me all these loaded questions
I was like yeah and then all of a sudden
the door busts open there you are these
[ __ ] fit in the fine
well you were hiding out where were you
at yeah I was in another conference room
on the other side of the building being
interrogated or just just hanging out by
the game guy with the angel yeah yeah
this guy's making moves so I looked at
Kevin and did um the dead lost total
control of the situation and uh they
called security
and we went back to our desk like pack
up our things and it was a lot of people
people were actually crying because we
had been there for like yeah like three
or four years we like really friendly
guys with everybody knew it oh you've
been working there for a while oh yeah
okay wow yeah so I'm in my um
a couple of secretaries down I always
used to talk to them they were they were
upset they were crying and it was just
and it was a horrible situation because
at the time when I got fired my wife was
eight and a half months pregnant
right and I was like so he was worried
about the insurance thing and whatnot
and my wife was like get a real job
YouTube's not a job so
not at the time for sure yeah not at the
time but looking back on that was such a
blessing for that to happen to us
because yeah that gave us literally a
year of unemployment to see if we can
make YouTube work and it eventually did
and yeah we wasn't making money the
whole time like the money was earned
like 50 Cent 60 Cent okay for me two
dollars this month yeah where'd it go
and then you know it was on unemployment
for um I think 10 11 months and right
before we got
um off on unemployment we made partner
and we started earning a little money
and we kept doing it kept doing it but
by the time our unemployment ran out you
know we was able to we wasn't making the
same amount and we was earning from AAA
but we was earning just enough to
survive so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]